A bit of a peek behind the curtain as to what's
been going on.
A great look into the chaos that is taking
place behind the scenes at the white house
came to us yesterday in the form of a vanity
fair article by Gabriel Sherman.
And one interesting little tidbit is that
Donald Trump has pulled Rudy Giuliani off
of Fox news appearances again because they
are so disastrous.
This actually is not the first time that this
has happened.
You might remember back in March, we did a
story called what happened to Rudy Giuliani
because we noticed that after some embarrassing
television appearances by Rudy, he suddenly
just wasn't being interviewed anywhere period.
And this lasted for some month.
Eventually Rudy resurfaced, but it is now
happening again.
Now, the public facing funny part is there's
old Rudy making a FA, uh, making a fool of
himself on television, yet again all the time
he's contradicting himself.
He's self incriminating.
He's admitting to things that Trump is still
publicly denying.
We've got to get Rudy off of TV.
But then there's the more sort of serious
behind the scenes piece, which is predictable,
which is that people around Donald Trump,
including Jared Cushner, his son in law, and
Ivanka Trump, his daughter have been telling
Trump, you've got to fire Rudy for the better
part of a year according to this report in
vanity fair by Gabriel Sherman.
Now, of course, Trump has not fired Rudy,
but there have been questions as to is Rudy
still Trump's lawyer or not?
But there's more and more speculation that
Rudy Giuliani could end up arrested over.
The Ukraine fiasco is two of his associates
already have, Trump has stood by Rudy so far,
but the pressure has mounted more and more
and now Donald Trump has at least in the immediate
told Rudy Giuliani, no more Fox news appearances
for you.
This has been corroborated seemingly anyway,
circumstantially by Fox news producers who
said to vanity fair, you know, in the last
few days we actually did invite Rudy Giuliani
to appear and he turned us down.
So it seems as though this is indeed what's
going on.
One Republican is quoted by Gabriel Sherman
in this article as saying, quote Rudy is cut
off from Fox news.
Now there's a second layer of funny, and when
you look at what was the last straw or the
straw that broke the camel's back on this,
it is something really, really funny at every
appearance.
Rudy has been a pathetic joke, but what pushed
Trump over the edge is reportedly when Rudy
went on TV on November 23rd and said, I have
an insurance policy against Trump in case
he turns on me, that did not go over well.
Rudy later tweeted that the, that the comment
was a joke.
It was sarcastic.
It wasn't for real, but Trump didn't like
it.
And at that point said no more Fox news for
Rudy Giuliani.
So as usual with Trump, it's, yes, of course
have Rudy do interviews was always a bad idea.
Your TV lawyer can't seem to help but further
incriminate himself and you.
But then the acute reason that actually got
Rudy pulled off is less about incriminating
Trump, but merely saying something that was
supposedly a joke that Trump didn't like,
which is, Oh, if Trump turns on me, I've got
an insurance policy against him.
It's a never ending comedy of errors.
It's a race to the bottom, so to speak, in
political discourse.
So now let's step back for a second.
At this point, isn't it clear that Rudy is
going to eventually be thrown under the bus
by Donald Trump?
I know that right now it's a fight.
We can't tell are they going to remain friends
loyal to each other or not?
If I were Rudy, I think I'd be realizing at
this point that I might be able to avoid it
for a little while, but ultimately this is
going to end poorly with Donald Trump and
he's going to throw me under the bus.
Why not go and try to make a deal right now
with prosecutors and with investigators?
Give them the goods, spare yourself.
What's so clearly seems to be upcoming?
Am I off on this?
Let me know what you think.
Send me a tweet at Dee Pacman or leave a reply
in a comment.
If you're watching on YouTube, what would
you do if you were in Rudy Giuliani's shoes
right now?
Would you just say, I'm going down eventually,
let me make a deal?
Or do you try to keep up with the neverending
demands of how you maintain loyalty and a
friendly relationship with Donald Trump?
Let me know what you think.
After the break.
We will talk about genius, sort of reverse
psychology by the French president Emmanuel
McCrone.
We will also, uh, get, uh, to in a very, very
[inaudible]
[inaudible] voicemail from a right wing or
which I think you will find both compelling
and disturbing all of that coming up, uh,
after this quick break,